hey what's up everybody my name is eric
nam and these are my favorite snacks
[Music]
oh oh no that was better we can't put
that on camera do it again please
hit me
i got it
this is called
if you have never had like an asian or a
korean sweet potato you are missing out
on the sweetest most delicious
caramelized hot sweet potato in the
world it's amazing because they come in
chip form
[Applause]
smells so good
[Music]
they like melt in your mouth but they
still have a crunch and a crisp it
tastes
sweet
and savory but not overpoweringly sweet
aren't you curious
you're gonna have to like tell me to
move on otherwise i'm just gonna keep
sitting
here it's like get him out of here
bam
we got some yanians there's a very
emotional story behind this i used to
love these well my mom would go to like
the asian grocery store the korean
grocery store she pick it up and i took
it to school one day and the kids in my
class had not seen these before i was
like they're like what is that it's like
oh they're like yeah and they're really
good they're literally
cookies with chocolate dip
so my teacher she takes one out dips it
eats it just like i did and she goes
ew yan yan in the can can and threw my
entire snack into the trash can which as
a second grader
i'm sorry i'm gonna cry real quick
it's it's pretty traumatizing uh that
your asian snack is gross and it gets
their way into trash can so this will
always have a very soft spot in my heart
and just in case you're wondering
they're not ew they're freaking
delicious don't knock it till you try it
hit me
you remember these right
everybody remembers these warheads when
you guys asked me to pick my favorite
snacks i think i just went down like
memory lane and just picked a lot of
things from my childhood but i feel like
they've been saying new intense flavor
for the past like 20 years
this is like misleading packaging here
oh no i was trying to make a cool video
moment didn't work out really but let's
see if these are as sour as we remember
oh yeah
it's not as bad as i remember maybe it's
because as kids were like more sensitive
to like flavors but it's not bad
warheads
you're welcome
oh
my god
i haven't seen this in so long
orbits nobody knows what this is you
guys who else remembers orbits does
anybody else remember orbits you now you
don't remember don't lie to me i grew up
in in atlanta georgia there was a water
called like clearly canadian they at
some point came out with this thing
called orbits now you're probably
wondering
what are the corn kernels inside this
thing
what are the cheese balls doing floating
inside of this
water
i don't know
i honestly just put this on the list
because i was like i haven't seen one in
so long i doubt they'll be able to get
it but the freaks here at snack got it
and i appreciate you where did you guys
get this ebay ebay you want me to drink
something from ebay
um i'm not gonna try this
but i just wanted to see if you could
get it it's like a lava lamp
in a bottle that you drink would you
drink your lava lamp no
but i drank this hey
kettle brand potato chips honey dijon
these can elevate anything you know
truly think about it
having a hot dog they can be really
really
bad nasty hot dogs but the moment you
pull these out
it's gourmet you can literally
imagine the potato imagine this is a a
potato that's about this big and they
literally just sliced it straight down
but in optimal thickness
it is not your lay's potato chips lays
crumble in your fingers
these are thick enough so that they
withstand the finger pressure yeah
you're welcome
youtube
yeah okay
now listen for the crunch ready
[Music]
it didn't even
fall apart it's a perfect little cut
look we're ending this with a bang let's
take a moment of silence
okay you know as a korean-american there
are many things that i'm very proud of
my heritage
and all things k culture we got the
k-pop we got the dramas we got the
movies one area that i think is is
overlooked is cakes
[Music]
i asked for this cake because it is so
damn good it is fluffy it is juicy it is
light it is airy when you go to a korean
cake shop they put in a nice little box
for you so you can carry it around
they always give you one of these knives
and they'll ask you do you want candles
because koreans are courteous we assume
that you might be going to a celebration
of sorts a birthday party an anniversary
graduation but because of that with the
knife there comes
matches
and they give you candles for free
because this is the first episode of
season two we're gonna
we're gonna sing
happy birthday if i can like that oh
there we go happy birthday to you don't
go out happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear snack
happy birthday to you
yay
[Applause]
look at that
sara lee ain't got nothing on this sarah
lee where you at
[Music]
all right well snack thank you so much
for having me and congratulations on
season two now i'm gonna plug some
things because that's why i'm here let's
be very honest okay i have a new album
that's out it's called there and back
again and the new single is called lost
on me also i'm on tour i have 52 shows
and counting in the first few months of
this year so
if you're around coming out with me most
importantly please stay healthy stay
safe be happy and i hope to see you guys
again soon have a great 2022 it's gonna
work out i
promise that but hopefully
okay bye
how much did you pay for this time yeah
overnight at like 150. what
oh my gosh you paid 150 for that
now you have to try it